géographie troisième mais cinquième
année aujourd'hui les secteurs
économiques
le support de court le syllabus
géographie notions théoriques que
parages 147 et 148 une économie se
subdivise en différents secteurs qui se
répondent l'un à l'autre le secteur
primaire
le secteur secondaire et le secteur
tertiaire le secteur primaire est liée à
la production de ressources
ça peut être l'agriculture que cela soit
l'élevage où la culture de chant ça peut
être la pêche ou la pisciculture
ça peut être l'exploitation forestière
autrement dit la sylviculture et
également toutes les activités
d'extraction que cela soit des mines des
forages ou des carrières
le secteur secondaire transforme ses
ressources en un nouveaux produits plus
élaborés
tous les industries font partie du
secteur secondaire ainsi que les
productions d'énergie les entreprises
agroalimentaires qui vont transformer
les produits issus de l'agriculture et
le secteur de la construction
enfin le secteur tertiaire complète le
tableau avec les services aux personnes
le commerce dans toutes ses formes
les services marchands le business to
business c'est à dire des entreprises
qui vont proposer des services à
d'autres entreprises comme la
consultance par exemple ou la vente de
certains produits les services
financiers les banques les assurances et
les services non marchands comme ici
l'enseignement à côté de ces trois
secteurs officiel il y à l'économie
informelle qu'on pourrait qualifier de
parallèle cette économie recouvre toutes
les activités qui ne sont pas déclarés
qui ne sont pas officialisé auprès des
organismes publics et de l'état
on y compte bien sûr les petits métiers
qu'on retrouve dans les rues
les vendeurs de nourriture les petits
métiers de la rue comme les cireurs de
chaussures ici sur la photo
bien sûr tout le travail non déclaré
c'est à dire le travail au noir qui ne
va pas passer par le circuit officiel
ainsi que par définition les activités
de la mafia des mafias qui évidemment
sont illégales et qui sont donc en
dehors de l'économie formelle la carte
de la belgique qui vous est proposé ici
montre la répartition de l'économie
belge
parmi les différents secteurs on voit
tout d'abord que le secteur primaire est
vraiment très très réduit en belgique
à peine quelques pour cent ce qui est en
verre sur votre écran le secteur
secondaire
l'industrie lourde la chimie l'industrie
légère rassemble ici à peine 25% de
l'économie belge
enfin tout ce qui concerne les services
les représentent la plus grande partie
de l'économie belge
plus de 75% vous avez le détail pour
chacun des arrondissements de notre pays
je vous propose une petite préparation
nous vous allez devoir remplir un
tableau de données à partir de certaines
cartes de la place pas de panique si
vous n'avez pas la place je vais vous
les proposer sur blu geo
les cartes sont notées ici il s'agit des
cartes 214 à 214 b 214 c'est de la place
mais de la 14e édition de 2014 mais vous
pouvez chercher la terre développement
dans les autres éditions
quand vous arriverez devant le tableau
vous allez devoir choisir un pays un
pays évidemment qui sera différent des
pays que les autres élèves de la classe
ont choisi si vous avez un atlas une
édition précédente de la place je vous
propose aussi sur blu géo un tableau de
correspondance qui vous permet de
retrouver plus facilement les
différentes cartes et donc comme je le
disais le scan de la carte est aussi
disponible aux jeunes vous avez
en main pour réaliser cette préparation
je vous donne un exemple vous avez donc
ici les planches qui nous intéresse vous
oublier celle ci qui ne nous intéresse
pas et quand vous allez cliquer sur le
lien suivant qui est ici répertoriés
mais qui est également mentionnée sur
blu géo vous arrivez devant ce tableau
voyez que je l'ait déjà rempli devant
votre nom vous allez mettre le pays vous
avez choisi bien sûr ne choisit pas le
même pays qu'un autre élève
prenez un pays qui n'a pas encore été
étudiée et vous allez regarder sur les
cartes
quelle est la répartition des différents
secteurs pour l'économie de ce pays là
donc il suffit de lire les cartes
correctement c'est un ces sables et ça
va très vite une cette vidéo est
désormais terminée je vous souhaite une
bonne fin de journée un bon travail et à
bientôt